we are all just our ancestors dreams
and our success represents
those dreams coming dreams coming true
take over
[Applause]
what is standard bearers of hip-hop
atomically be on top of the game right
now
see that's the limit son let me take a
moment and appreciate where we're at
I don't know what it's like in hip-hop
everyone is looking for the next thing
my point is is that we have to do
everything the whole opposition while we
got it
I always envisioned a better life but
y'all taking it really far we're
two-thirds through the recording budget
we started on the show for it at some
point it all comes down to delivery what
if [ __ ] is going up in my face butane
needs heat right away or you're dead in
the water I'm looking for a new style
and tongue always needs to be moving
forward stop trying to control
everything it's only a matter of time
before they start to present you for are
you changing our brand y'all can't just
trust me yo how about you trust us
I can see it
[ __ ] is way more fun when it's out of
control son
of money from us that they owe
they gonna sue us for money we don't
have we got work to do
killer be killed what you want us to do
go to war we gotta win
all the time
Wu-Tang versus the world
[Music]